Chris waters here at San Diego comic-con
I'm at the microsoft showcase as you
could tell and i'm here to talk to Kiki
wolf kill of 343 industries about halo
night ball halo 5 Guardians and pretty
much any other halo think she'll talk to
you about Kiki thanks for taking the
time of course maybe just a tiny bit of
halo 5 Guardians okay I'll take what I
can get oh so let's start with nightfall
you guys have been talking about it a
lot here at comic-con we spoke with the
actors from the show you guys had the
panel today how's the reception bin for
you guys really bringing out more
nightfall stuff it's been great and it's
crazy because we just came back from
shooting and you know we haven't really
been talking about it we announced the
title and that's about it and so
literally we've all just come back from
shooting and suddenly we're here we're
talking about everything we're showing
pictures or showing footage and I feels
like we haven't even kind of gotten our
heads around being back from from
production and that's great from the
wilds of iceland's to the balmy San
Diego atmosphere I well let's talk about
nightfall because I mean that image
we've all seen of the broken halo
crashed onto mystery planet I mean
that's the first halo yeah alpha halo
and you know it's really been an
interesting experience because we've
really got to play with what is the
alpha halo ring in its destroyed state
like you know what what really stayed is
it in its in a sort of trying to fix
itself and not quite right and so it's
extremely different from how you may
have experienced it before and it
allowed us to really sort of creatively
play with all sorts of different things
because you know it's a man-made
structure it's going awry and and it
just leads to a lot of really
interesting situations for the
characters yeah this is no mere dead
asteroid or broken piece of a planet
that this has like self-sustaining
systems the Sentinels 343 Guilty Spark i
mean there's a lot of stuff going on
under the hood well
343 Guilty Spark ah there's a lot of
forerunner technology going on under the
hood but yeah I mean it's intriguing to
think about a structure that is that
sort of technologically advanced and and
how does it try to repair itself when
when when it's broken so to speak and
what could go wrong and and forerunner
technology is unpredictable and what
mysteries does it hide of course I
talked about in the trailer sort of this
elements that was found and this thing
you sort of you know my gamer mind is
seeing it just charting new mechanics
into halo 5 I mean it's propagating all
of this wild imagination stuff and I'm
pretty sure that's exactly what you guys
intended so we're very focused right now
and just sort of what setting the
characters can live in and we did you
know we did want it to be more than just
landing on a planet right and so again
it kind of gave us the flexibility to
play with some dynamics in the
environment that maybe aren't very
natural all right well let's talk a
little bit about those characters
because we were talking with Mike Colter
and Christina Chong earlier about sort
of their characters and how he
eventually becomes a Spartan but this is
his origin story and how she sort of
sees him as a role model in some ways
and sort of what kind of dynamic are you
trying to create amongst the sort of
protagonists of nightfall well you know
it was fun because we were able to sort
of set up this these two forces between
you know the outer colonies sedran sort
of colonial guard who are maybe a little
backwater right there working with
decommissioned UNSC equipment they felt
abandoned by the UNSC because you know
they've been ad left on their own in to
their own devices and then you have only
come in and Oni you kind of we've had a
few peeks into Oni but you've never
really sort of seen the the boots on the
ground operatives and so it's kind of a
really intriguing mix of super high-tech
used to having all the equipment all of
the technology at their fingertips and
then you know the subject colonial guard
who really are about
kind of living by their wits and sort of
surviving and so what does it mean when
they used to come together and when they
actually have to accomplish something
together and then again what do that
what does that look like when you know
they're they're sort of forced to make
decisions around their own survival so
it's it seems like a pretty tough
challenge for you guys to not only
create the sort of interesting conflict
this dynamic this sort of the beating
heart of nightfall but then also keep in
mind sort of the ripples throughout the
Halo universe and of course 343
industries as the stewards of all things
halo you know there's a halo TV show in
the works there's the game coming up and
there's the Lord knows what else you
guys are cooking up there in Seattle I
so nightfall it's sort of the second
live action kind of big initiative you
guys have done after Forward Unto Dawn
do you have anything sort of your
carrying from that experience into this
one that sort of helped you I mean I
think so we're so proud of forward unto
dawn and you know that was sort of an
expansion on a lot of things we've done
before kind of in the live-action
commercial space um but yeah I mean this
idea of sort of bringing a character
from sort of a dramatic live-action
piece into the game and really exploring
the character with different story
telling something we kind of did with
Forward Unto Dawn but with a secondary
character this time we're really taking
a character front and center you know
that you will play in Halo 5 and saying
you know what let's take a step back and
spend time and tell a story in a way
that lets us really develop who he is
and and who he becomes at the start of
Halo 5 and hopefully get people to sort
of invest in that character with a
little more emotion than just starting
the game fold and saying here you know
take a controller and love this guy
right or hate this guy right however it
may be give them some sort of lead in
that way and so halo nightfall is going
to be available with the master chief
collection is that right it is included
as part of the master chief collection
so episodes will start airing when the
master chief collection releases on 11
11 11 11 nice all right Kiki before he
closed out there's like a whole arsenal
of halo weapons here would you mind
closing it out with like a Charlie's
Angels pose with me you feel it do you
want oh yeah oh yeah absolutely it's the
back to back you want SMG or Magnum you
got it all right we're going to do this
hold on
you